يوصف بانه اسوء شتاء يمر في البلاد مع
سلسله من الاضرابات غير المسبوقه في شرط
القطاعات في بريطانيا يكاد لا يمر يوم في
ديسمبر دون اضراب في قطاع ما حتى ان
الممرضات نفذنا اول اضراب لهنا على
الاطلاق بجانب عمال البريد وسائقي الحفلات
وحتى سائقين سيارات الاسعاف لتحسين الاجور
والظروف المعيشيه لكن بالنسبه للسياح
الذين يختارون بريطانيا
يجب ان يستعد للتعامل مع اضرابات عمال
السكك الحديديه وعمال الامتعه في المطارات
الازمه الكبرى اضراب موظفيه الجوازات الذي
يبدا في الثالث والعشرين من ديسمبر في سته
مطارات رئيسيه ابرزها هيثرو في لندن نصحت
الحكومه شركات الطيران بالغاء 30% من
الرحلات الجويه الاحتواء الازمه عن
احترازي تستبدل الحكومه البريطانيه موظفي
الجوازات ب 600 جنديه من القوات المسلحه
لا دائما عامهم بشكل مؤقت
[موسيقى]
تسيطر اوروبا على الكعكه الاكبر من
السياحه وجذبيه مدنها للسياح في عام 2020
وفقا لتقريرا صدر عن شركه ابحاث الاسواق
البريطانيه يوروبوليتر قبل نهايه كل عام
يتناول تقرير سنوي لدرجه الجاذبيه 100
مدينه في جميع انحاء العالم عبر السيتي
فئات بما في ذلك الاداء السياحي والبنيه
التحتيه والصحه والسلامه والاداء الاقتصاد
للمره الثانيه على التوالي بسبب ادائها
السياحي الاستثنائي لهذا العام
اما اماره دبي الاماراتيه تاتي في المرتبه
الثانيه بالقائمه حيث وصلت اكثر من 12
مليون رحله دوليه الى البلاد وهو نحو ضعف
ما كان عليه الوضع في العام الماضي
امستردام ومدريد وروما في المركز الثالث
والرابع والخامس ورغمى الاضطرابات في
بريطانيا الى ان لندن قفزت مرتبتين الى
المركز السادس ميونخ وبرشلونه وبيرلين في
المراكز السابعه والثامنه والتاسعه على
التوالي بينما تزيلت نيويورك الامريكيه
ترتيب افضل عشر مع ذلك يتوقع مؤشر ان
تعافي اسيا مع عوده سفر الدولي سيحدث
تغييرا كبيرا في ترتيب العام المقبل
تنضم الينا من الدوحه خبيره السفر
والسياحه نغم البداوي نغمه يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك ابرز وجهات السفر في نهايه العام
مع اقتراب موسم السفر اقتران موسم
الاجازات اين تنصحين بالسفر في موسم
الشتاء يسعد صباحكم نادين وسيم رغم زي ما
قلنا كانت من افضل الوجهات في الموسم
الحالي اول موسم بعد قيود كورانا ولكن
الازمات اللي تكلمت عنها هي اثرت بشكل
سلبي على القطاع السياحي كمان الكبير ولكن
ما تخافوا في عنا واجهات مناسبه جدا في
هذا الموسم اللي محبين قلب شهاد الشتويه
واللي حابين نستمتعوا بالثلوج نحن بننصح
به ايسلندا
همم باضافه الى التزلج هناك العديد من
النشاطات اللي ممكن نعملها مثل التزلج على
الكلاب استكشاف الكهوف الثلجيه واللي حاطط
الشفاء القطبي بلائحه الاشياء اللي هو
حابب يشوفها هذا افضل موسم لمشاهدتها في
ايسلندا خلال هذا الموسم كمان المدن
والقرى حتى تتزين في اعياد الميلاد رغم
انه الليل طويل ولكن اضاءه ازياء اعياد
الميلاد جدا شيقه ورائعه ولا التسوق
المحبين ايضا تزلج انا من صاحبي سويسرا
خاصه الاسعار هتكون اقل من الموسم الصيفي
والمدن والقرى اللي موجوده على نهر عين
حيث تتزين باعياد الميلاد والاسواق
التقليديه ويمكن ايضا الصعود الى القطارات
الى جبال الالب والتمتع بالمناظر الجده
الرائعه
المحبين التسوق وايضا موسم الشتاء فنحنا
منصح بيه نيويورك
باسعار جدا مناسبه
الصغيره
والمطاعم التنوع الكبير في المطاعم
والانشطه والفنون
ايضا تم اختيارها من افضل المدن للاستمتاع
باحتفالات راس السنه الطقس هلا رح يكون
فيها معتدل الى الخير تنتشر على ضواحيها
الشواطئ جدا الرائعه كما هي قريبه من
المناطق السفاري والتجارب المختلفه
انت هلا هيك قسمتي
المدن وقسمتي البلاد يعني كل واحد حسب
اهتماماته لكن دائما يتصدر او يتصدر مدينه
تراند سواء من خلال الصور او للفيديوهات
فهل يمكن الحديث عن مدينه شتاء نهايه هذا
العام ما هي
همم مدينه جرميد في سويسرا اه اوكي هذا
الشتاء تتمتع جدا يعني خاصه في اعياد
الميلاد تتزين كثير كثير اسواق فيها جدا
تقليديه وبنفس الوقت اسعار مثل الفنادق
وقربها من مناطق التزلج اللي هي الجبال
المحيط فيها فهي جعلان من اكثر المدن اللي
احنا بنصحيها انه الواحد يستمتع فيها في
راس السنه طيب شركات سياحه معتمده عالميه
مثل اليورومون عندما تضع يعني دوله في
قائمه الدول الاكثر همم استقطابا للسوريا
على ماذا تعتمد بالمعايير شفناها السنه
باريس بعدها دبي ودول اوروبيه
طبعا طبعا على المؤشرات القدوم السياحي
الموجودين وبعض الاستطلاعات العالميه وبعض
التقارير من مجلات كبيره مثل سي ان ان
ترافل ترافل على هذه الانجازات كمان
بتعتمد على الارقام التقديريه للسنوات
الماضيه طبعا قبل فتره كوفيت مشكله كوبيت
تعتمد عليها على الترنس وعلى الكروتريد
معدل النمو اللي كان متوقع الى هذه هلا
طبعا في اعتبارات اخرى للسياح مثل الاسعار
مثل الطقس مثل
الطائرات الرحلات المتوفره للطيران هذه
كلها كمان بياخذوها في عين الاعتبار الامل
غلط
يعني كانت تحكمت في السنوات السابقه
بوجهات المسافرين اليوم هل توسعت خياراتهم
ام ما زالت محدوده بعد ان دخلت اوروبا في
ازمه الطاقه واصبحت باقاطارده بسبب شتائها
القارس والبارد
طبعا هو الناس احنا هنفكر ان هي اصبحت
محدوده ولكن هي مش اصبحت محدوده خلت
العالم تختتح على وجهات جديده ممكن تشوفها
مثل موجوده في افريقيا مثل الموجوده في
امريكا الجنوبيه امريكا واسيا خاصه شبه مش
موجوده الا في بعض الدول مثل الصين وهذه
الدول ولكن في معظم الدول العالم
على وجهات جديده ما كانت هي على اطلاع
عليها او على معرفه فيها فهذا وسع وهذا
اللي احنا دايما ننصح فيه خبراء السفر انه
دايما ما تروح وما هو التريند رايح او ما
هي التقرير رايح العالم كبير وفي اماكن
وجهاد كثير حلوه ممكن يروح عليها خاصه في
وطننا العربي يعني احنا الدول اللي انا
بنصح فيها في الموسم الحالي هلا في الشتاء
اجرها هي المدينه
غير هي يا رب فيها والمعروفات يلا نروح
عليها شكرا جزيلا لك من الدوحه خبيره
السفر والسياحه نغمه من قدام